we have over 2,000 pigs 2,000
pigs why did you leave UK to come to
Nigeria why must I sett in abroad the
Zeal the passion in me as an
entrepreneur I believe in settling in
Nigeria work with Nigerians achieve
whatever I want to achieve all my life
I've never had a time that I say I have
like one week holiday I see myself
working every day every day that I see
myself Idol I know the is not feeling
fine we breed
pigs and also run production of
livestock feed and I'm happy that today
here has produced a lot of farmers and
people have heard about us for nuke and
cranny of the state and neighboring
states this is the biggest pig farm in
plateu
[Music]
state
what's up guys it's Simon AR again and
welcome back to the channel today we are
bringing you a wonderful video and we
are here at po gas pig farms and we are
here with the CEO engineer UD yeah thank
you it's nice to meet you sir me too
pleasure is mine my
name is OB now I'm the MD AUST Farm
science Industries
limited basically we breed
pigs and uh also run production of feed
livestock feed these are what we do here
we're trying to see how we can you know
bring things together that we can offer
what government are not doing what we
heard about them doing before but they
don't do it again in form of employment
in form of startup of business form of a
forum where people can come and see how
they can start up their own businesses
and I'm happy that today here has
produced a lot of
farmers in this place and people have
heard about us for nuk and cranny of the
state and neighboring states as a matter
of fact and to the glory of God I think
this is the biggest pig farm in plateu
state wow God is helping us we are
striving and going higher and higher our
vision is that one day our farm will be
one of the best farms in terms of scope
in terms of best practices in West
Africa uh we are competing want to
compete with Global Services best
services so that we can offer the best
to our customers and end users and also
bringing other potential Farmers on
board the young guys instead of waiting
for white jobs we ask you there are some
things we can do on our own that can
provide
employment that can may make weth by
what we do so this is the place this is
the
arena so uh where where are we now okay
this is one of the pens this is one of
the pens this penc okay we have a this
is C in penc we have piglets this is
where we doile our figlets figlets yeah
so let's go and see it so we have to
sanitize yes you have to sanitize so
these are our
piglets when
our our piglet at a certain
age um basically 4 weeks
we tend to win
them
wow I like how organized everything is
yes yes like I told you that this is the
work we do you can see how clean the
environment is so um how many pigs do
you have in
total well we have over 2,000 pigs 2,000
pigs 2,000 pigs yes you have different
breed so they are all the same breeds no
no we have different breeds we have
breeds like d Rock we have hsh we have
land race we have large whes we have
curo we have uh cross durok we have
Danish protest we have u a lot of them
in total like how many bre we have like
over 10 breeds 10 breeds that's a lot
yeah yes so um how did all of this start
how did you start all of this well this
place started um well far back 2020 2020
the co year year so that every all of us
were locked inside the house yeah so we
are deeply into construction industry so
at that time government and
other uh
other uh business agencies shut down
their shops that's true because of the
because of the co so with found
ourselves in the house and lock
ourselves up but before then don't
forget we have
workers employees under us so every
month employees will put a phone across
and say a what about our salary we have
not SE so as a man don't work as a man
we must pay because if you don't pay
they will come and look for you at home
and um based that we have worked we have
a Cod relationship at work we cannot
deny
them so I have to think Which Way
Forward we think outside the box and say
there's need for us to start something
so that we not notice that what we do is
what we should tell oursel the bitter
truth that we don't have any permanent
work we only had a temporary work
because a contract work is a temporary
work so we start
yeah
2020 start building during the coid we
will come here we put blocks we started
from the other side we put
blocks just one block two blocks three
blocks at the end of the day we have
about over 10
p p f p f what do you have in p f here
we have Growers growers okay when you
say grows what do you mean by Growers
Growers are those that have matured from
piglet sh
okay so they have grown they have win to
attend a a mature State stage so that in
this area this place you now see the PE
tend to add rat yes exibit some maturity
stage in their body in their body begin
to see them own okay so they are now
becoming
independent from their mother they tend
to become mother or father what's the
average a pig can give there to like
average numbers okay a pig
can average
of 10 10 okay does it depend on the
breed or all of
them mostly large white and L Rich okay
we have witnessed 19 19 wow yeah
this place we W 22 22 yeah uh but
averaging 10 10 so they can give birth
to8 6 12 14
5 it depends on nature we have also
witnessed P giving birth to one
one is Justin the is my name I am the O
the owners
representative I act the capacity of the
MD in case if it's not available so
where are we in the mail meil yeah
that's what you call it warehouse
warehouse what do you do in the
warehouse this is where we compound our
feed okay your feed so you make your
feed your yes we make our Fe ourselves
okay for
example this what we have here is the we
offer we offer yes so these are feed
yeah these are feed okay this rice
brand okay over
here we have the the S beans the S beans
okay so there are a lot of additives
that are involved that I may not mention
during our formulation so that's is what
we do here to making sure that we have a
quality feet that we give to our P to
making sure the way you have seen them
eyes they quite healthy yes quite he
that's what we do here yes this are
machine for mixing and this here A
machine for grinding okay grinding grind
the M ground is those are the two major
thing that this machine does but there
is the mixer where all the
additives I put them together and I mix
them with B them
okay so if we start to customer custom
okay you sell this to to customer how
much does the bag of this cost
H I may not give per head because we'll
buy in tons in tons okay are the major
challenges you faced in Pure Gas like I
said the challenges we face is
economy our economy is harsh in
Nigeria as a
whole you buy something today tomorrow
you will not get it and the people your
customers would not tell you how much
you buy raw materials all they are
concentrated is this is the price you
have placed this if you are saying you
are selling a kg of
pork 1,5 it should be 1,5 irrespective
of other adops in raw materials for
example we have raw material we use like
Maze and other grains a bag of maze is
goes for 60,000 per bag back of 100 kg
so by the time you compound and other
element other raw materials that those
the one we imported by the time you
compound them together and see how much
a kg of feet goes you will not able to
sell a pork the cost price that is I'm
talking of the the the the production
cost will not be less than 2,000 naira
per kg and if you sell it you will not
see people that will patronize
you so we are struggling to to come out
considering our production cost we are
struggling to pay our overheads our
bills because the cost of production is
high so it's a huge challenge if our
economy will be fair will be better that
things are easily accessible easily
bought then other people can even come
on board
so that is the major challenge we face
like I told you recently that we are
blessed with customers from across the
neighboring states like kaduna
Abuja uh nasarawa Benway anambra and
other states is because we we don't look
at that cost I was telling you we are
looking at how can we bring more people
on board because I believe
the greater we are into this business
the better for us we subsidize our rates
we bring it
down and allow other people so long you
have that passion to be in business we
don't look at the monetary aspect of
it we look at how we can help you to
start up your business so because if we
want to look at how much we spend to
raise a pig a piglet we may not sell so
we look at what is possible how if we
have brick even on the cost of breeding
a big to certain level we're good to go
so like piglet we have the one we can
sell as low at
25,000 30,000 depending on the breed we
have also a breed of 60,000 we have
breed
of 40,000 what's the highest amount of P
I'm the one I'm telling you
140,000 piglets for
piglets okay so it depends on the uh on
the brid yes okay so what of bigger pigs
how how do you sell them okay I'm
talking of
Life yes we sell 1,000 we sell 800
depending what you are buying now we
sell one two depending the the the the
quantity you are buying if you buying in
L scale large scale we s we reduce money
uh if you are just buying few uh it
depends but ranging from 800 to
1,200 what's your advice to um someone
wanting to venture into pig farm or any
business at all in Nigeria uh I say that
young particularly the younger ones we
shouldn't because our government have
disappointed us we shouldn't be
lamenting in our government as a result
of bad
leadership you understand we should we
should roll our sleeves and come on
board look for something you can do it
might not be Pig faring it might be crop
farming it might be another venture you
want to do don't give up roll your
sleeve come out and see what we can do
and I'm also extending this venture to
other
enterpreneurs let us see how we can
touch
lives let us see how we can touch lives
by bringing people around us anybody
that shows passion in this business we
encourage them by helping them to start
up that business and there a couple of
them have been sending messages and
prayers that is enough for me as far as
I'm concerned they pray for me every day
by day God bless you God bless you God
bless you you are the reason why this
business is still functioning today and
we are good I know
tomorrow God or someone God has put in a
position will remember us yes that's my
belief so I call on you I call on other
people friends let them come on board
let them come patronize the P AUST come
and be partner with P guys we offer
Training Services here we are
Consultants here too uh even other
people who have farms and they're having
issues we have uh
professionals you know medical
professionals around us who can offer a
better advice and revive their Farms we
don't want to see any farm that winding
down or close down or not functioning
all Farms should be alive so that we can
synergize together so guys if you enjoy
this video to like share subscribe and
do all to patronize Mr HUD of biogas so
I'll drop the details below the video so
that you can see and reach out to him
I'll see you in the next video